il y a trois jours un obus est tombé sur
l'appartement dans lequel habitait
Angelina
c'est la chambre où nous dormions il y a
un grand lit maintenant
et les murs se sont complètement
effondrées
sur le côté droit je bois
la frappe a décidé Angelina et son
copain Maxime à réservé un bus pour
évacuer backmout
Angelina avait déjà dû quitter
l'appartement familial 6 semaines plus
tôt
le bâtiment s'est effondré frappé par un
missile une partie des habitants s'est
retrouvé coincé dans le sous-sol et son
mort et 8 membres de la famille
d'Angelina étaient sortis ils ont
survécu
à ce stade toute la famille a évacué il
veut partir aussi mais mon père veut
rester s'il quitte la ville ce sera pour
aller en Russie nous ne sommes pas
d'accord moi je suis une patriote dans
la famille on évite ce sujet
le lendemain matin dans la cave chez un
ami Angelina et Maxime récupère les sacs
dans lesquels ils ont entassé toute leur
vie
je suis très heureux de quitter le feu
de cette zone de guerre mais je suis
triste d'abandonner ma ville je
reviendrai un jour
le bus d'évacuation est conduit par des
volontaires qui ramassent les civils
dans les villes proches des lignes de
front et les évacues gratuitement vers
les zones sur aujourd'hui Angelina et
Maxime sont les seuls passagers
d'autres fois c'est 15 ça dépend le
problème c'est qu'il n'y a plus de
réseau téléphonique donc on vient à
heure fixe et on prend aussi les gens
qui arrivent à nous joindre
c'est dur pour ces deux jeunes de
quitter la ville où ils ont grandi
[Musique]
hier j'ai pleuré c'est vraiment dur je
n'avais aucune envie
de parler il n'y a pas de travail pas
d'argent on a froid et faim tout le
temps j'ai envie de vivre pas juste
survivre
prochaine arrêt la grande ville de ni
pro à 260 km à l'ouest là-bas Angelina
et Maxime devront se rebâtir une vie en
attendant que la paix revienne à
backmouth elle a sorti de la ville un
immeuble est en feu il vient d'être
frappé par l'artillerie
les conditions de vie à backmouth sont
devenus si dures qu'une très large
majorité de la population a fait le
choix de fuir sur les plus de 70000
habitants qui peuplaient cette ville il
n'en reste plus que deux à 5000